I started crying and he just kept like
telling me that I like I was being a
good girl and like petting my head and
and at one point he was like choking me
concealing her identity for fear of fan
backlash the 24 year old says ho guards
spat on her slapped her and made her do
something she didn't want to do help me
down and force me to it ain't no sex
with him
she says ho guard didn't wear a condom
and didn't stop assaulting her
even as she bled from her vagina and
anus in a journal entry to CBC reports
she writes about not being able to sit
for two days although she never filed a
police report she says she did see a
doctor a few days later in this apparent
medical record it shows that she was
tested for sti's that she had mentioned
being assaulted it was the worst day of
my life and I'll never forget that day
Dolman says she first came into contact
with ho guard at a we'd a concert in
Ottawa two years ago where she was
volunteering ho guard communicated with
her the event through snapchat but she
says the two didn't meet face to face
until two weeks later at the Thompson
hotel in Toronto where she says a hotel
employee led hoe guard know when his
quote regular room was ready
the woman says quote of course I
expected sex I'm not naive but he
completely crossed the line and his
statement ho guards lawyer says the
singer met the woman through tinder this
is ho guards 2016 profile picture on the
dating app according to ho guard they
had consensual sex quote jacob is very
sorry that she is upset but that does
not change the fact that they made a
mutual plan to get together to have sex
and they did just that at no time did
jacob act badly or do anything without
her consent